the goddamn thing who gives a [ __ ] about
a plane no wonder people would get
mugged complain the past by [ __ ] the
plane [ __ ] the [ __ ] plane it's Monday
Tuesday the 27th the [ __ ]
August it's almost over
what are you doing with your [ __ ]
life the church and what's happening now
is brought to you by zip recruiter
listen you know how hard it is to hire
somebody today with all these Momo's
walk around it's real hard you put up a
sign next thing you know you have 22,000
applicants nobody's qualified you gotta
sit there then lie in to you and that
it's over you know why
zip recruit is here zip recruiter sends
your job to over a hundred of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply for
your job and right now the church family
you can try zip recruit it's the busy
season for free that's right we're
opening up the for free you get it right
now by going to zip recruiter dot-com
slash Church that's zip recruiter comm
slash Church zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire and guess what else it is oh
[ __ ] I'm making you money when you
[ __ ] sleep [ __ ] ego you ready
it's football season that means ching
ching one better week no parlays no
teases and take that fantasy and shove
it up your mother's [ __ ] well go and
straight-up gangster you understand me
with who with my bookie this church is
brought to you with my bookie football
season's upon us
you like winning [ __ ] the money right
you like betting sports right well I'll
tell you where I put my money you ready
my bookie calm right now they'll double
your first deposit use promo code Church
CH you are CH to get a hundred one
hundred percent bonus on your initial
deposit
up to $1,000 who does that feel nobody
uncle Joey that's so visit my bookie dot
AG today
that's my bookie grab a pen my B oh oh
kie dot AG and don't forget to use the
promo code Church for you dumb [ __ ] CH
you are CH and start going to church
because you need it anyway create your
account and claim your bonus you bet
you win you get paid and that's at
alright [ __ ] go to my bookie dot
AG kick this [ __ ] melee are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what
that's how to start a [ __ ] podcast
[ __ ] got Jessica Wellington in
the house
you got the grace killer what's
happening Jessica I'm good I got my cool
today but I'm good and then you showed
up with two [ __ ] narcos what good is
that you can get Lupul and stop and
riding you fill the prescription and we
have a little more cool part good
afternoon everybody hey everybody its
Nick with the hammer nobody feels
nothing I didn't ask Felicia if I should
bring something because I wanted to try
to be classy
yeah I was like a cheese plate there's
no and what drugs or a sandwich from
[ __ ] Encino the spicy Italian and you
prefer the drugs did you it's narcotics
whatever you got worried we won't take
them that day or maybe we will you know
you never keep anything like you just
leave okay take a bag you take it
immediately you never say anything
that's why tell people what's going on
Jessica Wellington's a pleasure to have
you on
I'm so excited to be here where are you
from originally I'm from North Carolina
and Florida okay do the worst [ __ ]
hellhole part of Florida Lakeland your
help okay go to Lakeland go to Tampa
can't go to all land they got gay ghost
right those gay guys that got shot
got a bunch of gay ghost Orlando flying
around just analyze the back your
[ __ ] love these things I have to
think of my wood you can't take away my
ways I've done my time my god I ain't
gonna talk he's gonna [ __ ] with you he's
gonna hide your shoes he said he's gonna
take every sock so you're left with only
one sock for one foot I'll take your
gloves okay and that's the type of ghost
I am a threat people yeah damn yeah I'm
trying to write a book and I had to come
to a hugly conclusion about my life that
I won the battle but I lost the war when
I was a kid you know Lee like I could
torture people forever
I could I could change your scenario if
I want God gave me that gift that I
could [ __ ] with people scenario and I
don't because it's an ugly gift to hat
but I did it for my stepfather I did it
to my stuff out it's like broke he's
fine he is to figure out his nut and I
broke them and to this now for the first
time I've admitted it was me who put the
wedge in between my stepfather and my
mother cuz I couldn't have my game if he
stuck around he wouldn't let me run my
game my mom let me run my game so for me
to get rid of him I had a [ __ ] of what
he loved the most which it was his money
I did that was among my stepmoms to be
fair I did but my dad he was my dad was
a great guy until he drank and then he
was an [ __ ] like he just Jekyll and
Hyde and he would hit women so a lot of
it was me like trying to protect them
too but there's a picture of me at my
dad's uh was my third and a second
stepmother at their wedding at the
courthouse and I was totally not for it
and I I just looked like I had an
attitude in every picture I wouldn't
look at the camera and all that because
I didn't want it to happen
um because you know he was a
continuation of violence yeah I mean you
didn't pull it aside and said get some
egg in the mouthpiece oh they would know
beforehand now this one I don't think
she did but also I was like 12 I don't
think it was my spot to be able to tell
her you know I mean but when it did
happen I told her how you know I took
care of everything I came in from
basketball practice I was so excited
remember the first time and then I come
in and I see my sister's on the couch
crying and I was like ah [ __ ] I know
what's happening right so then I just
went went to the kitchen saw the bottle
poured it out and I was like okay let's
go no let's just go well he's doing
whatever he's alright out we need to go
and um so I you know helped him in that
way you know it's crazy how how much the
seventies in the eighties for people
don't know this there's a lot of younger
people listen to the podcast there was a
time in this country where every block
had an abuser oh there was one woman who
lived on that block that always wore
sunglasses that clothes would be on the
front every morning or his clothes in
those days the cops are just coming
nobody would get arrested yeah you know
there's a there's a horrible called
domestic violence situation that's
always been etched and then 90 was you
witness domestic violence and it wasn't
my house I saw arguments from my house
and my son my mother hit him with a
[ __ ] thing one night when he left but
the people two or three down doors down
from me growing up in North Bergen he
was he was a drunk and he would get home
too and he would just be there he be
there was a week and it was well known
and nobody liked him on the block like
none of the kids we put we flatten his
ties we'd do everything Kennedy just a
[ __ ] annoy him you know and I think
one of the worst beatings my dad pulled
the gun on him and they broke up but if
I knew her she probably went back with
him then
different neighborhood the violence
continued yeah it's so weird how much
the whole J thing changed the tone in
the country it was accepting right
I just watched something on TV the other
day there was a movie shot in the
eighties and it was still acceptable
what about The Longest Yard
yeah we're into that was the seventies
in the beginning but it's so we like up
to the eighties it was still remember 89
I was five and my dad got so drunk that
he was holding a gun to me and my
stepmom pointing it at us to get on her
knees and say her prayers yeah so that
was 89 and I remember I called the cops
before when I got older and one of my
stepmoms she was out on the porch she
was raining she had a black guy and I
call the the cops and they come and then
she says everything's fine I don't like
well I'm gone
I'm not staying what happens do you real
mother you know Miami asked she
overdosed how old me I was 25 did you
find them
I did not I was living in Florida at the
time it was kind of you see how that
happened and where did she owed yet in
her trailer what kind of drugs no she
did I think was just pills at this point
my mom and AIDS but that in Medan killer
she had that for like over ten years but
her drug of choice was crack cocaine
you've had an interesting life
your eyes have seen a lot of things a
lot of people haven't seen and that's
always very interesting in a person you
see that in a person who's really weak
there's a couple weeks ago you came up
to me go one can I do your podcast and I
go when the timing is right you know
that just don't book people the timing
has to be right and I always knew you
were the first door girl at the Comedy
Store but I didn't wanna I didn't want
to bring you in here for that you know
stana talk about that later on I get on
the plane last week and I put on the
meal
a little bike under the seat backs our
bikes and I was very proud like you know
anything about me
IKEA will se atomic I cheer when I see a
comic on late-night but I cheer more I
see a comic in a movie because I feel
that over the years agents have not
utilized us how they're supposed to
utilize us you even watch a movie and
not to be your pistol go I should be in
this movie yeah like I've done enough
work that that could have been my role
but you agents don't see it that way the
agents have the road so they'll put you
on the road first because usually film
was in TV you don't pay a lot of money
right so especially in today's system so
when I saw you in that I was like god
damn you know now I thought back to the
auditioning process what was it like to
audition for Clint Eastwood you know did
you meet him at the audition he was
there this might be anti-climatic
because I honestly just taped it I was
actually in Dallas at the time doing
sets and I went to a place that it taped
I sent that in and they just booked me
off the tape how crazy is that
yeah now then how may days you shoot it
was just two days nothing
yeah I enjoyed it and Clint I did get to
be clean cuz we were in the same unit he
was really nice you need to try to make
little jokes he's old yeah when they get
old like that it inspires the fort I did
a movie with Dick Van Dyke he used to
have a TV series on oh yeah years ago
him his son and I got to be a bookie I'm
Willy APUs odes really yeah and it was a
great [ __ ] experience because I knew
one of the writers I forget his name he
passed away great guy the Irishman he
lived in that building in Marina del Rey
where you don't leave well you don't
leave you don't leave like they got the
movies they're single Chinese oh no
there's a building in Marina del Rey
that you just
only think of Bali stickin 24-hour
fitness they got routes
oh they got Whole Foods they got movie
theater they go in you know ya know it's
for people who don't want to leave
dry cleaning laundry everything you need
is in that building
you don't leave we would be there riding
you know the deserts up a cafeteria or
we want to eat spaghetti I order from
this place downstairs everything is in
this banks so I became dear friend room
he wanted to write he was from the Bronx
and he was gonna dick Van Dyke's close
his friends I couldn't believe it and
yeah I want to be hired me and I did
four days in the first two days I
couldn't look at Dick Van Dyke I would
cry pray to God that he wouldn't come
over to me like I had wine doing his son
and stuff and then at one point dick
looked at me goes whoa you know why do
you empty is in your eyes I know you
don't understand that ah
you're everything to me I learned how to
speak English because of you he was like
what people tell him fine they learned
about commie from watching the moon when
you work with alleged what did you take
away from the lease with like what was
it that made him stand out in front of
you he seemed I don't know he just
seemed easygoing you know is everything
that everybody was telling me it seemed
like that was exactly takes we did a few
but that's mostly for him because he
doesn't remember the lines I'm resting
right so you just you know he had to do
him a few times he directs it yeah
somebody else's cinematographer and he
tells you the scenes in the cuts did you
what's that one they you first go there
and they says see what the scene is they
call it something blocking blocking oh
yeah did you block with him I was here
blocking um well he didn't have to do
that we did that okay you know he had
stand ins and all that for that stuff
which I got to learn on Grace and
Frankie what a stand-in is all about and
that's the way to act
that is the way to act I didn't have to
do anything I was like you mean I'll
have to stand in my own light okay I'll
go out for coffee I'll be back when it's
time to act
didn't anyone do like my first job here
was on TV show and I remember so uh
someone coming in before like my boss
came up to be like don't look him in the
eye
what do they say anything weird to you
about Clint cool actually you know what
they all laughed at me and they thought
it was the greatest thing because he had
this thing of cherries that he was
carrying around in the scene because at
a farmers market and he was eating these
cherries well we cut and I just uh I
just looked at him and we were talking a
little bit and he was trying to tell a
little jokes and I just took one of the
cherries and ate it and every thought
that was just so arias that I would just
go to you know upon myself and eat one
of Clint's cherries and he thought it
was funny and I was like it's just I
figured it was cool he said dykes on
bikes I know
thanks thanks eat giggles or something
he giggled and I think just you know
when you work with people that caliber
you go Jesus Christ I'm connected to
colleagues with Matt yeah I had a scene
with Clint Eastwood like why is that I
didn't have a scene with DeNiro I had to
move with their oh yeah a grudge match
now I'm connected to their oh you know
and I'm connected to the narrow through
death what's the deer hunter because I
did a movie with John whatever the white
dude it so it's so weird when you start
meeting people and making different
connections like now you connect this
dot with this dot it's really weird you
like acting I do do you really like I'd
really do what do you like better stand
up of the acting I love stand up I love
making people laugh but I find that I
could I do that in both so I like it
even when I'm doing something serious
usually there's a part that you could
make people laugh I've just done
audition when I got here in like three
years ago three four years ago you've
been with the same agent since day one
you have a great look to you I mean
somebody thank you somebody will
you know in a heartbeat you know you and
I don't have the ordinary no look that's
why I love you i watch your podcasts all
the time because I feel like we have a
lot in common in Felicia always doesn't
in my face like all Joey laughs just
like that or that's how Joey holds his
mouth and I'm like what else
that's what Joey did he just did acting
gigs that get him along until okay you
know accepted me as a stand-up you know
everybody said well you have to book a
TV show to get on so did you take an
acting class no I used to do improv
though I started with improv okay only
like by a few months then I started
doing stand-up as well where'd you go
study improv I started at the Sacramento
common spot in Sacramento okay and when
I got down here I did I Oh because I was
easy I could hang on at the bar I was
actually like the only girl to work the
door there too that was on Hollywood
Boulevard
yes where are they now they're gone
they're only on in Chicago there's no
iOS anymore just i/o we do not go and
what happened to the one in Hollywood
they were doing so good for a long time
I know but something they just didn't do
things right I think that no it was yeah
they needed to keep the bar open I think
longer or something cuz the bar let me
tell you so I started hanging out there
yeah I quit the Comedy Store in 2007 got
clean by 2007 and a half I would start
they had a stand-up Neven mic on Fridays
at midnight or like 11 they did stand-up
and I would go over there it's one guy
would say you're Joey Diaz in the store
yeah and he put me up there was so much
industry that I got there it was again
it was sickening everybody was looking
for next they were good at that Saturday
Night Live guy so I was I told some
tango guys you gotta go some new spots
at the I out like I went three weeks in
the world came back with a card all
three weeks
nothing really transpired but electioned
all the people like the classes there
again
get to classes there Jeremiah did too
cuz you know he does he wants to do more
sketch and stuff
the problem with it that I felt was that
the people that were teaching the
sketches were bombs yeah the problem
that you know what I can pay this guy 75
bucks at each man's new sketch I can
actually pay a guy from Sinai alive to
do a six week course and I'll pay him
the two hundred of course over time to
learn from somebody who's actually doing
it
the problem with all the programs in
this town that I feel bad for people now
is that we don't know so we don't ask
right but if I knew what I know now when
I come to you acting class I'm gonna go
is this something Michael watch your
real seriously but then again I could be
wrong because I could be dealing with
who's the basketball coach that coach
the Chicago Bulls to all those
championships coach the Lakers to for a
while name the Chicago Bulls if he was
ready when he was a Knick he wasn't the
best player in the world but many an
experience he ended up becoming one of
the best coaches of all time so that's
the other frame of thought so I'm not
here putting anybody down and just
saying it I know this has a lot of the
people that teach courses here don't
tell Jackson Phil Jackson Phil Jackson
wasn't the best I'm gonna being a kid
the next foot in Phil Jackson Miche on
the TV are like we lost Phil Jackson's
gettin put it he was known as a
defensive specialist because he hadn't
lanky arms he would throw you off but he
ended up becoming one of the best
coaches of all time and that's what
pisses me off about this town that they
have a lot of half-cocked people mm-hmm
telling people to dream that they're not
qualified to sell it really gets the
time it's because they just didn't get
to live their dream so they're like well
well that's what it is you know I know
for a long time like advantage of it
that's a great acting school especially
if you're a woman because of Anna breaks
you down what's her name again
a valid shopping no sounds like a ice
skater Ivana Chubbuck is a good lady and
her coaches a good people Chris feels
this is the Chris's his name Chris
something he's a great he teaches
Tuesdays at 10:00 a.m. they have a
really structured program that beginner
medium and then your goal is to reach
Thursday night at night that's when the
heavy hitters go in when you walk in a
Thursday night you look around you like
wow
then you've done acting classes oh yeah
it's a muscle yeah you know everybody in
this town complained
no come on get booked you know nothing
cracked me up more when somebody would
go to Montreal get a half million dollar
deal act his home TV show and they can't
and then the network doesn't I know that
if I'm if I get a deal from Fox I'm
calling my management go on any show I
qualified for Fox better put me on to
nourish me along and make me a star put
him on a ride him into an episode of
this ride him into an episode of that so
by the time his show gets picked up he's
established itself it's really like a
spin-off of all the other shows you've
been on yeah that's my train of thought
but that's not the train of thought here
why does it surprise you that you think
I went to acting class um I think
there's a lot of stand-ups come from the
notion of you just got to get up on
stage and do it and not necessarily take
a class that's why I had the same notion
but you can't solve $10,000 a piece of
presentation with a $10 pair of shoes up
I know that it as a comic if you're
doing spot this to store constantly or
The Improv constantly the Laugh Factory
or anything that you're doing the store
that acting class as a beginner acting
class on a a night or an afternoon when
nothing's going on even if it costs you
a car payment it's not gonna pan out
that day but it's gonna pan out in six
months because it teaches you how to get
working
I also can't see you with some of those
actors I could see laughing and I am I'm
not a big fan of the phone yeah yeah
yeah I am NOT a big fan of that I think
that you could talk all the Stanislavski
in the training you want and I'll show
up with two [ __ ] hard-hitting
black [ __ ] queen with last ass
IceCube only acting classes he took
before Friday do you find was hands here
yeah so I run from two schools of
thought you know this there's you'll
never see a comic and the Harrison Ford
movie because Harrison Ford has always
felt that our timing is better than
anybody else's and we do have exquisite
timing but I feel that you should know
listen man the first time I got booked
in this town I got booked for a CBS
pilot started with nine pages of
dialogue when we shot the pilot you
normally pay that at now on zero because
I thought my arrogance and what I heard
from looser comics was that you don't
need an acting class but I also had a
mentor named Rick Newman who had done a
bunch of movies with Tom Hanks and a
bunch of people then he told me to get
into a class just to get myself around
did I get into that class no cuz the
arrogant said to calmly stone all the
other spots told me I didn't need an
acting class then because you and I have
a distinguished looked week a book on
just looks that's what happened my first
movie I did and I sucked right and those
people will never use you again you'll
never get a chance around them again
yeah and it's not your fault so I booked
for episodes on an NBC show I'm ready to
go I had booked BASEketball I didn't
know what I was doing when they told me
to step on the mark
I had no idea oh yeah yeah like well you
don't know how many times how to grab me
by the arm and move me up and how many
times it would say action
and I would talk without action and I I
just those guys if they ever see me they
just spit at me
the two guys that's been trained man
three about how is just a horror show no
but this is what happens for being
arrogant this is what happens for being
a know-it-all the one that's final me
was the four-episode arc on the show on
NBC if the people weren't as nice as and
I got fired from the shelf and tell them
all no I got fired the first day I was
on a fire and strength so I booked
Telemundo get that paid to my after
basically ball paid for my sag I don't
know but when I went to do this MBC show
it was Sidney Poitier's daughter it was
John asked his son there was a bunch of
sons and daughters some movie stars so
they were very nice to me but if you
don't think I went home feeling
humiliated I went home feeling
humiliated well see I was an ignorant
bliss I didn't know it was bad at the
time yes it's bad it is you're gonna get
the chance and you're gonna [ __ ] it up
yeah and you gonna [ __ ] it up against
people that matter yeah when your tape
comes across that death that never gonna
look at that tape again because you
weren't prepared you didn't stand right
you didn't [ __ ] play then I was a
comic which meant what am i shooting
it's a movie go eat a bagel go to your
room me I want to shoot right now yeah
so for 13 days I'm basically why did
like 13 or four guys I'm baseball I
bothered them all day long what am i
shooting if I want to know what I know
now you bring a notebook huh you bring
that on iPod you watch TV and you write
jokes yes not me watch what a [ __ ]
kick box and look at the sweat from a
[ __ ] black sweats she would kick box
what's her name Kelly Jenny McCarthy I'm
doing a sporty spice I'm sick and I'm
watching them monkey getting nice and
sweaty and I would go on the trail and
bang
and look through a little window a
bathroom because I'm the savage but the
point being when I done that movie
Josh will forgot the deal I call Josh
like a man I go I can't keep doing this
I have the ability to book but I don't
know what I'm doing
can you lend me money to get into an
acting class and judge Josh gave me
enough money to sign up for Matijevic
for three months it was really nice of
him yes so that's what helped me back a
lot is the money so what I would do
especially in the beginning was do
background stuff whatever I'd little
like commercial things I did for coffee
bean stuff they didn't pay much and
there wasn't like any residuals or
anything like that but I would do it
just to be around and absorb everything
and see everything worked
that's one hand that's one way but the
other way I go back to comedy I never
want somebody to see me as an extra ya
know there's people who yeah get it get
a slip how many slips do you need three
three I got it all doing now you're the
worst that did like a featured
background on ok yeah the worst I came
from the back school if you're an open
mic here an open mic I don't go get [ __ ]
around with people you're not supposed
to get seen and the same thing with
acting when I [ __ ] up all those seeds
I called my agent like a man I said
don't send me out for nothing else he
said what are you talking about cuz I'm
just I'm just ruining it for you so what
I did was every Wednesday I would run to
curse on to 7-eleven and I would get
that acting newspaper yeah I think it's
out of business there and they had every
college short film and then I was
getting shot uh-huh and that Wednesday
instead of going to bed I would send out
the envelopes Thursday morning so I
would get the call
cuz they have no money so your audition
is usually gonna be on Saturday and
Sunday at some [ __ ] library I mean
I've been taught dishes at the park they
have no money you audition in a park
the only problem with the ones where
they don't pay at all is getting people
to show up well listen it's like stand
up
easily given nobody nobody shows up to
their first an open-mic in a Maserati
okay I haven't look doing a shot up here
now you think about it Seinfeld has just
ended and like the lowest end rider on
Seinfeld got NBC or somebody to give
money for some sketch show and I
remember that I got paid $100 a day to
get hit in the face with a pie Wow I
thought the dude was doing on purpose
and I go hit me with that buying still
see the guy at the part we still got a
shot that pilot no you don't that's been
18 for 18 years yeah you know it's just
I did a thousand things let me tell you
something let's be correct on something
you don't know how many nights I did my
one o'clock spot at the store and it had
a 4:00 a.m. call downtown for some
[ __ ] no paying job
I've never doing a movie with a bunch of
Chinese people never went to the [ __ ]
review it was just our feet your feet
were in it just shot people feet leapin
alcohol maybe there was such bad
cameramen that we shot it right here by
Vitello's and it was a story about
valets that were burglars were you eat
and they would burglarize your house
that your car and your keys and take
your registration and go to your house
and Rob you and I was one of the valets
and I'll never forget that I shot two
[ __ ] lights tonight from 2:00 in the
morning to 7:00
cuz they can't afford it right and I
never forget they had this fancy you
know Puerto Rican will premiere over on
Sunset like in some [ __ ] dump and
I've never forget leaving the movie
going out there goes to lights in my
life and it back but the camera guy was
the camera guy from Bronx Tale a Spanish
guy and I talked to him all night about
so I even though I worked for free I
picked up something yeah so I worked for
free in movies I did that's a dude I'm
with friends with now at least to
Toronto I still have been doing a movie
with him that we had
a porno house up in the [ __ ] hills
and started midnight two nights in a row
12 to 12 shoots zero money 12 to 12
isn't that primetime firm midnight to
watch 12 about two 12-hour days I did
the mezzos for free I played a game ops
2
I was slated a monster hello a Friday
Saturday and Sunday for free I shot that
in 2003 and I was shooting movies that
there were certain things I would shoot
just you know it all comes down in the
pipe like it all goes into a piping
comes out of the bar so when I need to
see a future as a stand-up even though I
was a store a regular I attacked the
acting and I took acting classes I stand
in Havana Chubbuck for about six months
and then all the auditions were on
Tuesday so it was defeating a purpose
Tuesdays or a big audition that because
they read you Tuesday they call you back
Wednesday you they tell your Thursday
you go to wardrobe Friday and then
Yeshua on Monday so Tuesdays used to be
a big addition day so I didn't go to him
no more and I hooked up with a black gay
guy that had AIDS
that was brilliant with him I bought the
Travolta movie with him I booked like I
was starting to get more callbacks with
him I started just doing private coach
just get a couch bring the dirty bucks
yeah and going to he know you could go
makes it we're all daddy usually go to
Havana chopper can pay $200 for a half
hour or you go to the other chick she
wants a buck 30 for a half hour what's
the one on La Brea in between Hollywood
Boulevard and whatever I just I still
get emails from her I got a creation
station they do a podcast
oh this chick and she's Jewish cute it
was pretty funny women no no no no
that's a [ __ ] cult in this town and
valid topic is a great acting class
that's not culty Leslie Khan
it's a sweetheart of a woman but her
school is a cult they respect her life
she runs it life that's what improv
tells he sleeps there from Monday
through Friday she charges buck 20 for a
half hour so if you have an audition and
you want to go over the audition it's
2:40 for the house I say you better make
sure you're working 12 of 15 days if
you've booked you know but she'll take
you to the next level there's people I
realized that I didn't know it all my
you have to come to that conclusion you
don't know it all yourself if you were a
young comic I don't want you to be it
[ __ ] Chico De Niro's acting school
but you gotta be working the muscle
somewhere yeah
there's I know for a fact there's a
acting class up here in the valley in
the garage on Saturdays in the garage
it's like 80 bucks a week it's Saturday
your doctor you're not going on the road
hey Sal ain't nothing to do anyway go
over there go over there Saturday from
2:00 to 3:00 and work that muscle where
and how to read the scene and then after
you do that for six months and you focus
on auditioning just a coal reading
workshops learn how to cold read that's
where your money is because once you
take the cold reading and that's three
minute
you know that's three minutes you do it
the Comedy Store mm-hmm I love your
auditions yeah about three to five
minutes do you understand why men she
sure is a genius yeah yeah do you see
where I'm going with this
I think so the next time you come to me
and you go Joey I don't know what's
going on to keep going in for these
movies and they're all one line what's
Missy three minutes
I gotta figure out how to stay in that
room for three minutes
and do one line doing this time Johnny
yeah everything is a plan here don't ask
you don't know so do me a favor
shut your [ __ ] mouth go to an acting
class because this all goes hand in hand
why are you talking to your dumb [ __ ]
open mic buddies at a coffee shop I have
to worry about who specialist this is
exactly what happens you fall into
negativity go to an acting class the
cheapest one and learn how actors are
getting work yeah yeah now you've Alan
listen man for years when I was opening
for Rogen I was making a great living
there's always booking - [ __ ]
co-stars and one get Starmont
you take a look at my and DB anthis a
little bad some of them were good but I
always knew that they were gonna come in
handy you're watched uh a-after studio
with the black kid that did the movie
with him he chairman Katie Holmes just
broke up Jamie Foxx yeah you know Jamie
Foxx changed his name of Jamie Foxx so
you get up on my comedy story should I
then Jamie but Jamie Foxx tells a great
story about playing the piano I was
grandmother would make him put a piano
he didn't want pipe in a pipe the hell
won't play football or play football and
when he got the call from a raycharles
movie he looked up and he thanked his
grandmother
thinking I am a nobody Mitsy sure got a
plan but she invented that three-minute
spot that's a plan that's to teach you
how to do a production in three minutes
you're gonna figure out that auditions
no more their productions I mean I got
sick of going in for one wine co-star
you know the fireman hey I'll get the
baby you know I'll take a hot dog with
mustard
you ever seen those things people those
TV shows somebody has to audition sure
and you
you go crazy auditioning for those
because you sit there for an hour
outside the door
listen to hi my name is Lisa at okay
yeah I'll take the size 11 yeah
thank you for coming in I'll take a size
11 so I would go in earlier and listen
even though my spot was at 11 I would go
at 10:20 and I wouldn't sign it I would
sit there and listen to her buddy's
audition and I would make sure that
whatever right there was gonna be
different whether people gotta listen I
do and you'll hear the same [ __ ] yeah
don't touch that that's my bicycle okay
don't touch that that's my bicycle hey
don't touch that that's my bison don't
touch that that's my bicycle and then
you walk in and go hey that's my bicycle
don't touch it and no go that's not the
line where it is right now
and when you go down the audition when
the producer sees that tape you will and
some guys like Clint Eastwood David
chase there's some guys who don't want
you changing the lines I remember I went
in and I'm not exaggerating I'm not
exaggerating
I lived here at a time when you went out
for three auditions at that theatrical
and two commercials you day started at
9:00 and it started at 2:00 of 200 South
La Brea and then that I'm Bundy and then
[ __ ] then you had to go to Santa
Monica at 5 o'clock to be a model for
your hands I did do anything it make you
way too high 45 minutes my heart and
you're looking at the clock with Santa
Monica and you walked in you put your
hands in puddles with soap then you pull
them out they're like thank you that was
phenomenal
hands really whose hands were you I was
my own but always like buying a dildo or
something Oh Janet's just my hand when
you tell people these stories they do
not believe it last week I'm being
Bing Bing Bing
Jellico when it's for Bank of the
America of deposits so that means it's
AG like a form in a row that means it's
AG tracks so I like at one thirty eight
cents I look at the other one one penny
I would get the other one forty five
hours and the other was like three
hundred hours but I looked at that one
anyone like I deposited the check for
its direct deposit right they deposit of
one penny check the best is when they
would mail you you know it costs more
than mailing who are you to mail a one
and people will listen go enjoy you
deposit one paycheck no I have direct
deposit from the Union I would look at
those checks I go wow I've been around
for a long time like I get what I get
residuals every month most people it's
nice when I make our residuals on every
month like I look at that thing I'm very
proud of that number it's not gonna
cover me or buy me a house but it's a
lot better than not getting anything
gasps it's my wife open up and go huh
four hours ago thank you [ __ ] for shut
the [ __ ] up at least somebody had the
audacity to send me 1038 and some day
that four hours of cover a Wendy's
Burger Drake it really does you know I
never understood the comic that
regardless of I don't like saying other
people's words you know well bollocks
said not to act that's great but bill
he'll die without insurance but even
when you do stand up a lot of times you
you're still saying other people's words
when you telling your story because you
can't have it without both sides so
what's the difference really I would
love it you know like I just when I came
here I knew well we have one shot in the
major this is the major leagues this is
Boston or Texas or anywhere else on the
disrespective and the other markets this
is Lex this is what decisions are made
you know so I knew for me to be on top
of my game there were all these things I
did you know you looking at me I took
four or five writing classes in the
aisle and my sketch writer no but I
guarantee I got something models yeah of
classes I was like a semester and a half
he was the head he was the head writer
of the show that Chelsea became a star
lately before Chelsea Lately that she
became a star on there was a girl or
sucker Kyra soltanovich there was a show
about girls that were play nasty tricks
on you oh yeah he was the head writer
this had to be 20 [ __ ] years ago
he was the head writer that's what
taught at IO girls gone bad
something about yeah well it's kind of
Impractical Charles behaving badly girls
behaving badly I know I didn't ken Jeong
wasn't - yeah a lot of people a lot of
people did that show that started a lot
of people's career but it's funny how I
don't regret anything I can't look you
in the face
I took the Christian cap was an acting
workshop he was the vice president of
casting at Fox
he was brilliant I took a workshop by a
cast if the guy who casted Godfather -
and Donnie Brasco I still have the
paperwork it was a birthday present for
my wife 2001 and I still go over that
list before I go to the audition really
yes it's a list to check yourself right
and then you make different notes on the
page that you're gonna read so you know
where the in functions are what the
character is thinking the moment before
he teaches you you know he told the
stories about the girl from asleep is on
her shoe around the [ __ ] doorknob
with a resume and a tape and put how do
I get my foot in the door you know all
those things of people really wanted
there's people who sound whenever the
Holly wouldn't be the star as people
staying
exactly how they're gonna do it to tell
you the steps on how they did I'd do it
you know I took all I paid for all those
workshops even though I was a junkie I
went out of my way I think that went to
the lady from NYPD Blue had a casting
workshop because not only it was worth
the 80 bucks of the 60 bucks because if
you decent at least they get to see you
and they keep you their memory and
listen Christian Kaplan put me in taxi
from the really workshop from that cold
reading workshop a month or two later I
got a call from him it was funny Bobby
Slayton had the wrong yeah the director
was friends with Bobby and giving him
the role I went in there and knocked it
off and I got a call now away the
Bobby's I can you [ __ ] believe this
I had three days on taxi and they hired
somebody else I go what room we've
explained the bicycle guy in the
mechanic shop right over them cuz they
had kids christian kaplan that you know
so that they used to have a paper that
told you all that stuff was available to
you where you could take all those
workshops and sums up some of them are
ripoffs
yeah check with me and I'll let you know
if you see one that's interesting I'm a
sadly is something like two to five
that's I I can't do in a towel yeah
that's too much information
nobody could do those but two to five if
they show you a little film they give
you material to prepare and they give
you notes on your material you [ __ ]
take a lot home and at least you got
that coveted now you'll know why those
three minutes so [ __ ] important she
was the first one to do that three-man
set I don't know yeah I didn't I was
asking him it she was the first one to
do the three minutes but think about it
how many people leave the calm you still
gone
I just I couldn't even tell a joke in
three minutes what do you want to get in
here yeah you better [ __ ] learn how
to do three minutes that's true and
while learning how to do three minutes
you also learned how to do
good audition you'll learn how to be big
at the room how to play in the rule this
is what nobody understands this is why I
tell young comics to shut your [ __ ]
mouth
you have a [ __ ] clue what's going on
you don't have a clue what the plan is
in front of you you have 50% knowledge
about what - [ __ ] you I think I know
what's going on you don't yeah it left
turning like I don't know all you need
to do as a comment it's go to acting
class right Tommy and get on stage
everything else in this town is far into
it people will come to me hey you want
to do I don't know what you're talking
about and how and I'll do those hundred
our day movies in those free movies but
I got to see that everybody is involved
when I first found out it doesn't matter
doesn't matter when I first it doesn't
matter 15 then come see me I did 15 15
or 16 knows [ __ ] mummy things well
none of them all we're gonna take this
to the USC festival get the [ __ ] out of
here I did one where we shot it then
they actually sold it you think they
called me no they called some real you
get beat up when it's camera time you
learn and you meet different [ __ ]
people you know somebody sent me I did
scare tactics scare taxes is back really
yes from 2001 and - it's on Netflix and
it's rocking the people that put it
together have been hit me up man in the
reach we did we tweeted it and I saw one
the other and then TV where it was me
and the guy that shoots Tony Montana and
Scarface at the bar when he set the bar
on the phone all [ __ ] up
- Colombians get up and unload on him I
met him on a scare tactic shoot this is
a guy that there were like greatest
movies of all time
and I met him and that's a complete
different muscle that's an improv muscle
that's a boss where I come in as a tough
guy and say hey you stole 20 kilos you
know what you're talking about I got a
scan you I watch myself one knows not
Wow that was a complete different muscle
well every muscle that you work all
leads to the same destination I hope
which is anyway and you're doing great
with it I really got a what's his new
show lead you says you would Jane Fonda
and Lily Tomlin are you [ __ ] crazy
I know it's just one guest role I had
like seven lines with Lily Tomlin and
Jane Fonda I play like a biker chick you
know so little you're at the store I did
was I did I asked her to do our podcast
because I just you [ __ ] up to the
store first I think she's gonna be
bothered cause she has to do a [ __ ]
podcast she said she'd be down I don't
know if she was lying to me yeah okay
whenever they were there she changed her
number already but Jane I think she
ended up liking me more at the end and I
literally did I thought that was I just
didn't think I was gonna go oh my god
she looks so [ __ ] good if you took
good care of herself she's I didn't want
to say old she is doesn't matter she is
up there and she still looks amazing I
don't know how she does how is when you
worked with Clint you worked at Jane you
work with Lily you know later on in life
I got to work with Rodney towards as
laddie is nice how was their mind like
well they sharp did you notice anything
I think Jane is sharp Lily she still
seems sharp to me but I think she's
always been goofy and that's just kind
of her personality um she's so cute yeah
she's such a cutie and then Clint and
say the moat the big thing with him it
just seems like he's slowed down but I
think he's with it well he shot that
movie he was denying it wasn't a 988
yeah I watched that movie three times
already because it came on HBO the week
after I'd seen blade now you want to
come on HBO so I watched it twice just
because I'm such a fan of his and just
to see what it's like to shoot at that
age like I wished God gives me the power
just watch my daughter grow and I can
act at 65 Jesse huh like I've done a
movie Portofino you gotta shoot him all
the people that shoot quick
there's no that's what I was asking you
about what's that Paul Sorvino yeah
that's what I was saying to you before
after we figured out the name when you
should when I shot with Paul ruined the
Lord you gotta shoot Paul
you ain't gonna be in the late hours you
just gonna it's the law of diminishing
returns every hour I mean he was falling
asleep in between takes Rodney would
fall asleep in between takes you know
these guys are a little over yeah I
can't really run them like you used to
12 hour day Lily time doesn't want to do
a 12-hour day no but well she did I was
so surprised and what a long day that
they did because they would and then at
lunch they would break and they would go
to a table read for the next day it was
like you know you're I can take a little
break at all like come on they would eat
lunch and they're doing a table read
they have not stopped working and then
you gotta think about Clint - he's down
there in that Atlanta summer heat and
that's nothing - you know scarf about or
whatever I can't talk you know at 88 in
the middle of summer in Atlanta and he's
doing scenes outside I mean a lot of us
can't even handle that on our own you
know when I look at those older guys
it's because your mind has to stay
really sharp you still gotta know your
dialogue you still gotta [ __ ] to have
your timing and I just give them a lot
of credit I really do you know Clint I'm
watching them the other day and I could
clean up please don't put Clinton like a
a fighting movies
no I could they're all all dude [ __ ]
like that but yes and I was right he did
give himself to three way to three ways
to threesomes what do you mean
Oh in the movie yes he did yes he did
yes he did they were [ __ ] pissed at
home that had a big ass why why do you
think people at that age still work
because like other other professions
people retire is it just the money so
good or they they actually have to do
it's love man
it's love if you ain't got love for this
ain't never gonna work
that's what most people never really
figure out that they sit here not 18
years they figure that you have to love
this because you take a lot of whether
they say yeah they don't pay yeah you
doing out of love yeah this is what you
do I don't know what you're talking
about
I have no idea what you're talking about
I'm here to do one thing I love doing
calming you have to fall in love with
something that it hurts you it hurts you
that you don't even at that level that
you have to hurt it's like when a girl
breaks up with you those first four
years I still remember being nine all
right last night I found a little
notebook I went through some boxes this
weekend and I found my copy though poo
from 2004 for no yes Oh
2004 do you know where I was last night
Sunday night whatever the date was what
was Sunday night's date says you know
where I was August 25th in 2004 that was
25 years ago right yeah were you in
prison no I was where I found I did two
spots that night I do the spa that's
amore Harpo's or something that I don't
remember
but the first spot I did was at 7:30
there was a collide dancing class what
and I came on at 8:30 last night when I
saw that I wanted to shower
expresso before I go that's my secret
yeah Comi so the reason why I go bananas
on stage because I'm a ball of expresso
I Drive with music I just get myself I
think of all the bad things people did
to music last night I left the house so
fired up without expresso I don't even
remember I did they have an expresso to
hit Sunset Boulevard because I was so
overwhelmed with that hockey table that
was the dunk 25 years ago 15 25 years
ago
1994 all right now 94 94 I was opening
up and a [ __ ] wine dancing night on a
Sunday night
that's and here I was 25 years later not
driving to a comedy club
driving to the world-famous Comedy Store
now do you want me to lie to you and
tell you that night I was doing my 10
minutes in front of those country
bumpkins that I even had the Comedy
Store on my mind it was no where am i
ray they're in my heart it wasn't in my
soul I just thought I was just a loser
comic you did that's kind of says the
truth first four years of comedy you
loved five years you shouldn't feel that
great things are not moving in your love
I love see I loved it I love getting
[ __ ] on because life has taken twenty
shits on you yes yes and this was better
so this is solid poops you know listen I
could sit there Riley let's say I'm
sitting there somebody's just taking
shits on me that's one thing but what if
I got my tongue up [ __ ] Charlize
Tehran's ass I'll keep taking [ __ ] to
the head while I like a little clicker
that if I'm licking that little click
I got that same burner ass working that
little monkeys open it up and you read
that thing I don't give a [ __ ] what you
do to me you could just keep throwing
[ __ ] on my head it doesn't really matter
[Laughter]
but it's the truth you know when you
first five years of comedy you just
taking [ __ ] if there's 52 weeks in a
year you're gonna have one good week
yeah you know which is seven good days
yeah I'm exaggerating I'm being a little
negative you're gonna have 13 good days
where you feel good about yourself out
of those 365 years then by the sixth
seventh year you start feeling 50 good
days like somebody's interested in here
for a festival somebody wants and send
in the tape you know saying like you
make strides but the first four year you
should be crying yourself to sleep every
night
your friends are calling you to get
married they doing this they're doing
that
for years I loved it because I felt like
where were you in Sacramento okay you
were late I didn't even know this was
something that I could do you know and
then all of a sudden it just kind of
shows up and I'm like you mean anybody
can do this I thought like I was so
ignorant to how comedy worked I thought
somebody saw you on the street and said
hey you're funny come with me that's
what I thought I probably I took you I
didn't know about special I thought a
guy showed up and did it now yeah pulled
off the street no work involved yeah I
thought anybody could just go up then do
an hour and just yeah that's what I
thought I didn't know anything about the
process you know I didn't know the
process yeah so when I found it it was
just like I finally cuz I had gotten out
of the Air Force and I wasn't sure what
I wanted to do with my life for six
years I'll see you get benefits and
everything now oh god bless you that's a
dental but you know I didn't know what I
wanted to do and then I found comedy and
it just felt like my whole life
everything made sense like why did I go
through all this [ __ ] as a kid and why
did I do you know it just all made sense
because I was supposed to do this
and I was so happy in the beginning and
you would go to open mics and I would
just drink and I you know would just
have fun with my friends and do these
open mics you know ignorant tell
everything worked and I felt like that
was my happy that was your bliss yeah so
yeah it was my bliss my first four years
were bliss because there was no head
shot yeah there was no resume any of
that there was little be about the agent
or casting director I knew nothing about
that all I learned how to do was how to
go on stage mm-hmm and I was in Boulder
where I used to have to hit poetry
readings and they throw me out get the
[ __ ] out you know well back in front of
music and anything it is man so you did
your open mic in Sacramento mm-hmm for
how long
four years and you would do like the
punchline all those places I didn't do
the punchline as much I ended up at the
comedy spot because that's where I
started that's a good spot and I ended
up managing there so did a lot there but
then we do it open mics and the bars and
anywhere else we go laughs unlimited do
that open mic oh and with sometimes we
would get a San Francisco and try to hit
up some places how long have you been
here for now
I think going on four years now Emily
we've been a door girl at the store two
and a half years and now we have the
prestigious the same then we have the
first female doorman to it I just kept
hanging out there and I wasn't shy about
letting him know I wanted the job and
then I was working for Tammy upstairs in
the belly room yep whatever this is
[ __ ] and you're like that's my type of
day Tammy had me out front
making sure people went to the right
direction to the right room and so since
I was standing out there I was like you
know what I already know how to do this
I checked IDs at the gates and stuff in
the Air Force I was like understand
check IDs for everybody so they can see
I can do this job
so I was just helping him out showing
people where to go checking IDs so they
could already see I could do it you know
and then I just kept telling I wanted
the job are you happy you took the job
yes I know have you been there for now
two and a half years what have you
learned
oh I'm still pretty stubborn but uh I do
I mean look at the people you get to
watch go up every night people you get
to learn from the people that I've
gotten to open for was been amazing I've
gotten to meet Felicia there and I
remember first time I met her was at the
back door and she came up to me and she
introduced herself and all this and I
was like hey I know who you are you know
and then I asked her to do a podcast
because at first I thought well are are
our voices would just be cool together
you know cuz I have more of a deep voice
and she's got that soft voice and I
would have never met her you know if I
wasn't working the door um so it's it's
opened up a lot of doors Busta Rhymes
kissed me while I was working the door I
mean now you actually watch the comedy
some nights when you have time
absolutely watch of look and listen
people always come in because they're
like they can tell when I'm there cuz
they can hear me laughing yeah I love
you know I work I was a doorman at all I
didn't know your door on Sunday nights
she would let me double between the MC
and the doors MC and work the door
that's how good I have been see I love
this so yeah lovely I never [ __ ] the
rest of peace she just so I was a
[ __ ] animal so she she like Cuban
people she was Jewish but she lived in
Miami for a while then she was really
impressed by the work suit when I first
met Betsy she told me how I love it I
got Cuban here they break their backs
for you and all this [ __ ] you know she
cannot insult them to battle your [ __ ]
submit see joy yeah
but it's odd how is the experience its
let you know what you wanted to do in
your life like you've seen some amazing
things up there you and I both know it's
an amazing amazing place like no other
honestly it really is there's such a a
grunge feel to it to that people have
you can just feel you can feel that
people pass through there and the things
that have happened there
and the people that come from all around
you know to know what they're coming to
see and they see the best comedy in the
world and I'm lucky enough to work there
and meet these people and get to know
them I mean there's a reason why all the
open my crews are trying to be door guys
at the Comedy Store how many they sweet
are you working it well it just changed
I was doing phones for three nights or
three days a week and now it looks like
I'm gonna be starting this week I'm
doing three nights a week again I would
just cover people here and there when I
was working phones and do nights just
whatever people need to did but now
looks like I'm gonna do about three
nights a week at the door and you act a
lot yeah I'm trying to book a lot I've
been doing better lately so let's hope
that keeps up but yeah it's been pretty
steady as far as when I first started
you know doing it like I said the first
movie I did that was sucked I was not
good you could see you could tell I was
like waiting for my lines okay but they
can fix on I think fix that yeah but
they edited it weird they were like in a
rush and for some of the funnest scenes
that I'd done they ended up cutting out
no you know that's how that happens a
lot of times and they made it all just
back and forth between these two houses
and I was like that's not the fun part
you need to break this up a little bit
so whatever it was fun it was the first
like real set I got to be on so that was
which was released would one know this
was the first movie I did was it was I
look
it said it was low-budget sag but how do
today hundred twenty five a day yeah
okay yeah up a little bit yeah
but it was uh it was learning experience
and they they had everything you know
there it does first studio you know
craft services and somebody there for
wardrobe but you would have on any big
studio production so it felt like it was
larger than it was I'm very proud of you
for taking that route a lot of comics of
stubborn and they don't know what I
always didn't want to be here 20 years
without a union card every [ __ ] year
I got the evening card and have every
one of them saved like they're so
special to me you know it's so weird
that like I told you I went down to the
store the other night so excited because
25 years ago not only was i driving to a
[ __ ] country-western bar who follow
achy-breaky heart but I would also force
myself to go there because I would have
to return to my daughter on those nights
so I was fighting the pain in my heart
and how bad of a comic I was you know I
wasn't a [ __ ] I'm achy breaky art joints
when my friends were what the Comedy
Works get but I I think of all those
things you know I think about doing
spider-man 2 and spider-man 2 a lady
would knock on my door walk me through
the gate and they pay the guy to tell
you don't step on that cable and then
they would have a guy I'm gonna open the
door at Sony and you'd walk in and then
another guy would grab you and ask you
if you wanted something to drink and
then when you got to the Train another
girl would come and she'd fix you up all
nice and pretty and then you got on the
train and you're like wow I feel like a
star dance
yeah are you late I did a hundred
dollars a day movie where you walked in
your thing and the award drop is not
enough mm-hmm
there's no lunch they let you leave this
set for lunch you're like what are you
talking yeah
whenever I get into a car yeah like I
was like blown away like there's no food
there was an apple and a banana and I
just come back and then so I'm very
proud of these things I did I started
with a SAG movie and then somewhere
along the line it was like scale then it
went down to like 450 I could live with
those whether the Rodney movie was 459 a
day yeah but it was rowdy yeah and I
worked 11 days and then I loved the
movie there was 250 a day that sag
low-budget then there was sag ultra low
budget was a hundred then there's
another sag that's fifty there is yes I
did a movie with a guy that was an odd
he was a featured extra
so you hung out but I don't I don't
understand that because he had contact
with the principal's so when you have
contact with the principal so they I
adjust a call from an audition and I
come up to Jessica say can I get you a
cup of coffee and I'm an extra all of a
sudden I become a principal well that's
because you gotta lie because I had a
line but I did featured like background
work extra work but I didn't have any
lines was the thing we were in an improv
class so that we just had to like mime
our lines or what we might be saying or
whatever so they just don't give you a
line and they don't have to make you
Princip that's crazy that's crazy and
what you do is so problem cuz they're
gonna call you fun
no it's not no oh when you do a soap
opera like when you do a movie hi I'm
the first ad I'm Jennifer let me walk
you to your trail because Victor's been
there for 30 years and services over
there you check in on ABC you know at
the end the sunset at the end of a
Leawood is that if you go on east now
west towards the beach if you're going
east no no no in Hollywood boy was to
the stand on Hollywood go up that little
block right
I forget it harder Hillhurst there's a
block Leticia ABC you pull back there
and you give them your ID employee Lizzy
and says you're an office 12 thank you
and you look and you're like I'll even
though office 12 is and you start
walking around and you go to your office
and you sit at home and your suits there
your clothes there but there's a
teleprompter and your sides of that and
the teleprompter tells you when you come
up you don't even allowed out there
it was very interesting you said how
about standings yeah okay because with
this you don't a lot out there they'll
say scene 32 now 48 is up next
go out there you basically even block
like they tell you whether standing are
so proper you do your lines you would do
a line you go hey the cabins on fire
if you say slate though they won't even
make you do a line over so just go to
the cabins on fire cut move it along
I said fire three days on General
Hospital I got it at 8:00 I was in the
car by 9:30 Wow
yeah soap operas rapid fire and they
just move that's why Victor's been in it
what's that I don't know his real name
is buddy's played Victor for how long I
don't want at least 30 years on General
Hospital and then the rest of the rest
yeah yeah people that have those jobs
they died
that's it yeah they're home by five so
it works out of answer that you get
there at 9:00 some days you don't work
your pay for four week it's not a bad
[ __ ] job but it's weird because what
were you saying about standing Julia oh
when I did Grayson Frankie that was my
first experience where I had a stand in
like somebody was paid to be my stand-in
so I didn't have to go out and you know
stand in the shot for them to set the
cameras and do the lighting and all that
she did that for me so I could just
relax
no I'm like this is the way you're
supposed to know have you ever read
anything about gene Hackman mmm no
Gene Hackman is a phenomenal act some
day I looked up to and he believes you
never leave the set so because he
believes you'd never leave the set I
never leave this set well I'm still like
Bob of the scene this times I would
stand there and people go you don't go
you go sit out I would stand and just
wait it out until the casting other
director was like it's gonna be a while
go sit down
I'll stand there because I want to see
the action in the pace of the set yeah I
don't know just want to walk up on the
set I go to the set loss sit like if I
have to shoot earlier Thursday I'm on
the Sun poison
go get lunch seho well yeah I'm gonna
get fitted but that's a lot I'm there to
watch the action all this said how he's
directing the style of it taste is he
doing how detailed are they oriented are
they I like go on a day before like
wardrobe when they they just come to
this side you have to walk through I'll
sit for two minutes and just watch kind
of watch my scene before me and watch
even if hat doesn't correlate with my
scene I watch it because I wanna know
what they don't know and I see the
cadence I want to pick up the cadence
you know it's so wheel Felician I have a
conversation the other night that this
is I think life offers this but our
occupation off is it war we never stop
learning you never started you never
stop learning and you know everything
that I've done in my life
compliments everything you know
everything I've done whether it's been
the acting class the podcasts the IO the
road stand-up the Comedy Store stand up
to stand up in the bars never till today
I didn't stand up on a bustling time
with a Disney bus in New York yeah all
those bombings they all come back to
help you later on they affordable
deposit
what it's so weird when you're in town
making investment here so take an acting
class for a hundred and twenty days and
see the correlation between see why
people keep the sets at six minutes and
three minutes I love people come to this
town I couldn't good boy you should open
three minutes all good luck okay because
you're not gonna be able to do anything
an audition three minutes you dumb [ __ ]
so it all goes back to handed and you
never saying oh you got a podcast with
falesha mean lies club yeah good I know
it's going good the reason why I can't
do it is because I ain't going
downstairs in that basement
I heard you notice anything about me
well come to you uh have you noticed
anything my uncle Joey uncle Joey in
twenty-two years been in that basement
three times yeah this is your windows ya
know it just I just don't what happened
to you if you were in a basement like is
it all basements I just it's just a
basement and I was down there before it
was finished yeah it was creepy
refinished
is that why you don't like the Train in
New York well I don't mind the trade me
I just found that you know I don't want
to be in a [ __ ] subway with people on
top of me with lights flying man come
here somebody's gonna stab me with a
sword
help me that [ __ ] right now when I was
21 I love the subway this action okay
worst-case scenario you get into a
fistfight no no I love all that [ __ ] the
comedy store downstairs I have my
reasons just it's too [ __ ] creepy for
me to hate there wasn't a difference
between my comedy store tenure this time
and my Comedy Store 10 your last time
there's one difference
I don't date the waitress no more and
something from mid sea shore where they
keep it light at the Comedy Store
I don't want to be involved with nothing
I want to be involved with nothing in
the old days when he got involved with
mitzi was something that project failed
your ass was on that [ __ ] [ __ ] so I
learned the Leo base I go there I do my
spots and I'll leave you ever seen me
promote my own show
now there's a reason I take from that
place what I need to take from that
place I'm gonna start doing a one-man
show in the belly rule I'm gonna start
working and on Wednesdays once a month
that I'll do but you don't see me
involved with that I don't go any deeper
I don't want to be any deep I don't want
to go downstairs I don't
yeah night your buddy go upstairs to the
bar upstairs
does it involve climbing stairs yeah I
can see the hill from here I don't need
to go upstairs for somebody well it came
to the comedy store my longevity was
because I kept the light like the adapt
I sat in the office I heard a little bit
of gossip but I got in the car I'm like
that's the first time I forgot Sapir
since I've been back because I don't let
myself get caught up
I don't it's a business for me it's not
a hangout it used to be a hangout but I
still never did coke that I used to buy
my coke there and I wouldn't do it
before I go on stage I'd do it afterward
but I always even though I was a junkie
I always had a weird respect for the
store couldn't do coke before the Joe
Rogan he would hate me so when I was at
the store I always kept on a certain
pace I never done Latino night how many
times she offered with my helmet eight
all night yeah you could have had that I
do the store a certain way for a reason
I keep very life I don't bother you you
don't bother me
and we all stay friends you don't have
to do the podcast and I keep coming down
here three times a week I will you know
I'm saying like I don't need to take
eight spots a week and do all the belly
room spots and I don't need to do that I
don't need to do it I'm not either take
food out of your mouth I'm here to help
myself be a better comic helper to show
be better [ __ ] the lead Sebastian's down
there yeah I gotta go now they're really
rocket you know saying like that's why I
never did I never got the boat Mitzi
shore on a business level
whenever people want to do some I bow I
keep the Comedy Store as a place I don't
ever want a problem then don't ever want
a problem that's why I've been there I
walked out of there in 2007 I didn't get
asked to leave I walked out there
because I wanted to walk on my feet not
walking on my knees that's the Comedy
Store you always want to walk out before
they tell you to leave
yeah you never say anything like so I
walked on my own two feet because I know
Tommy was gonna lose his head and the
other [ __ ] more I was gonna get both
their heads had the tool so I had
already done my stint and if you're in
any club of you if you start at the
funny bone in Omaha
you got six years before you could have
to move tower right I have two cities to
club only you've already done New Year's
you've done
Thanksgiving you've done the fourth of
July as a headliner you've opened for
everybody
what's your what's your longevity in the
comedy club when you first time I had
never done New Year's so this past New
Year's I hit up Burt and I was like can
I do a guest set with you I forget where
he was and I think it was like San Jose
or something he was like you can come
down hang out and then I got there and
he was like you really want to do a set
and I was like well yeah he's like have
you ever done New Year's I was like no
it's like I don't know if you really
wanted to do this but you just sit back
and watch this time and it is different
I've never started done in New Year's
it's a blowhard it's a blowhard
because it's people I wrote don't really
go to calm you all the time yeah they're
just out for the one night off the one
that it's [ __ ] midnight I gotta stop
what I'm doing accountant when Dick
Clark do you I'll do New Year's I've
done enough of this I did the first 20
of them I never got the money everybody
talked about I never got extra money
oh wait don't know he is you're gonna
make a lot of money on everybody else
god I never got it I got it I just dealt
with drunk people and people be in the
air again and a couple years ago I just
said it's not working
I just stopped doing the love doing it
this year either I'm going away I'm
taking the girls game for the week
almost yeah I'm not gonna be here for
New Year's I wasn't here for Lulu years
last year either not worth it not to me
at this level write to me at this level
but I did the first 18 years of New
Year's I think I didn't do my first in a
second everything after that is two or
three of them going up a dry storm I'm a
[ __ ] going up before holzman being
broken I would open for Rogan at the
improv and then we'd do two shells and
then we'd shoot over to the store
honestly I hated all three sets yeah it
was just a [ __ ] [ __ ] like one big
Bachelorette yeah yeah it just wasn't
but you need to do them so you need to
learn how people I thought New Year's
you know one of the biggest debts I ever
had was like is in Miami I went on that
stage cocky boy and it was numb
bumblebees and [ __ ] snoring I had one
even party I just went back to my hotel
room and cried but then somebody told me
it's a different audience but that's all
[ __ ] they're all the same
people it's just it goes in your head
New Year's you start thinking
differently you think they're thinking
differently and it's just people that I
don't like Louise you have to really
enjoy it
salad you know I like doing a New Year's
show early to let people go do what they
want
yeah because it should be like a dinner
and a show - yeah yeah get the [ __ ] out
nine o'clock go to your buddy's house
jump up and down with the Filipinos I
don't want to do that I don't had 12
o'clock I'm gonna be home I don't want
to be clock in or countdown or whatever
so you do the Lions Club you have a
website I do the Lions Club website or
mine yours at funny Jess Wellington calm
listen man you're making some great
strides
thank you I always want to get you on
the podcast I just want to be there
timon now is the right time have you
seen you have to look at my Instagram
mean Felicia did that age app thing and
we took a picture her and I together and
she looks like she's still doing a
podcast with you cuz I looked exactly
like you I just appreciate you and I
appreciate your heart and your balls as
a woman then and nothing pisses me off
when people say women ain't funny in
there you are a [ __ ] trooper working
the door so you have an open invite and
you always have a spot in my heart
because you're the real deal great thank
you this is an honor
yeah cuz I am a fan and I watch it yes
it's whatever you want to and hopefully
I don't do me a little favor maybe get
together with Lee and busted money yeah
we should move in together tip top into
his room in the middle of man for sure
that's a porno [ __ ]
anyway the church what's happened now is
throw these goodbye zip recruiter listen
hiring is a challenge
zipper kuta makes it easy nice and easy
hiring is challenging but there's one
place where you could go while hiring is
simple fast and smart a place where
growing businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiter
dot-com / Church like I said
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans through
thousands of resumes to find people with
the right experience and invites them to
apply to your job zip recruiter sends
your job to over a hundred of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of five employers who posted on
zipper Karuna get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
and right now the church fan
get zip recruiter for free you like
chili what are you talking about free
just the holiday season's coming you're
looking to hire this is the best thing
for you to do go to zip recruiter calm
right now slash Church CH you are ch ch
you are CH and find a qualified
candidate for the position you're
offering all right zip recruiter then
the smartest way to hire but right now
you got to go to the zip recruiter comm
slash Church zip recruiter the smartest
way to hide the church is also brought
to you by oh [ __ ] it's my [ __ ]
people my bookie dot AG dot dot AG
listen it's time to make some [ __ ]
Gators football seasons upon us
we got khabib against club playing
Poirier we got college football we got
baseball coming we got everything on my
bookie calm ng right now okay so if
you're trying to bet on the NFL baseball
MMA whatever my bookies got it they got
better incentives and more lines than
any other sports book period and this
year they're running a [ __ ]
tremendous contest a hundred hours to
enter you pick five teams a week against
the spread and wrapped up the [ __ ]
points first place is $100,000
guaranteed how do you like that
they just revamped their site and it's
looking [ __ ] tremendous so go take a
look if you haven't already now do me a
favor what we're gonna do this year with
my bookie 8.8 G's gonna do is double
your first deposit right now that's our
week that's how we're gonna [ __ ] them
welcome in all right use promo code
Church grab a pen CH you are CH to get a
hundred percent bonus on your initial
deposit up to $1,000 you heard right
who's better than you you deposit a
[ __ ] thousand dollars and you get
what I got a thousand [ __ ] dollars
so visit my bookie dot AG today
that's my bookie that AG and don't
forget to use the promo code Church when
creating your account that claimed the
bonus you bet you win you get [ __ ]
paid and I'm gonna have a little special
treat for you guys starting next week
before the football season on my
Instagram so if you're not following me
on instagram your [ __ ] slipping I
also want to thank the best on it comm
listen those coconut almond seven gram
of protein shoes they have they've kept
me alive all week [ __ ] delicious and
the new half a brain and the powder that
you drink mixer water [ __ ] even
better listen and it never stops and it
don't sleep they creep while you sleep
go to adam.com right now and look at the
great selection of supplements they're
gonna blow your [ __ ] awake alpha
brain the powder are you [ __ ] kidding
me the taste tremendous I got the alpha
brain I got it stacked up I got my alpha
brain I got my [ __ ] shroom tech
immune a got my shrimp export I'm
getting ready for the [ __ ] holiday
season if you think I'm gonna be sick on
Christmas Eve [ __ ] no I'm showing up
with a [ __ ] big dick in a mistletoe
and I'm saying so go to inot calm my now
press in church and get 10% off
delivered right the house do not forget
the ice house is sold out there's a few
tickets left for the Majestic Theatre in
Dallas I think there might be a few left
in San Antonio on the 14th but the
Chicago feed is alive and kicking
that's on the 27th it's gonna be a
[ __ ] tremendous show many I'm ain't
gonna tell you who's gonna be on that
show just go get tickets right after
Labor Day go enjoy Labor Day go hang out
with your cousins jump up and down eat
potato tots and that [ __ ] when I come
in I'm coming in [ __ ] heavy to
Chicago so don't forget the Friday the
13th forget the black cat it's uncle
Joey in Dallas at the Majestic sadly I'm
at the Aztec theater and Santa Anthony I
think it's all sold out and on September
27th the Chicago theater [ __ ] be
there or be square you bad [ __ ]
I'm leaving you with a tremendous song
called endless love by Lionel Richie and
Diana Ross alright I hope you enjoy it
I'll see you [ __ ] Thursday
morning
tip top
[ __ ] Magoo kicked this melee